all right so we've talked about how you
can clone or repository so you can work
on it in your own development
environment just in case you're
interested in working in the with the
command line a little bit here are some
of the more common commands that you
would use with git now these are just my
opinion and you will need a lot more
commands than just this but this will
get you off to a good start git clone is
what we talked about earlier this is how
you can clone a repository down to your
local machine you'll notice all of these
start off with gift GI T that's an
important piece to remember now you
don't have to memorize all of these at
once but I do want to kind of explain
them just a little bit get pull remember
how we talked about the remote
repository that everyone has their
changes you know uploaded to that when
you run it get pull you're bringing down
the changes that some of your colleagues
might have made and pushed up to the
remote repository git branch is how you
create a branch on your local machine
remember we don't want to make mitts on
master we want to create a branch first
we check out to that branch with get
checkout when we do that we're letting
it know that any commits that are made
we want them to be on that specific
branch git status is maybe my favorite
command you can run git status at any
time and it will tell you exactly what's
going on you can use this at any point
in time so following the github workflow
a little bit we created a branch and
we've made some changes and we want to
store them as commits we use git add
before we use git commit now we'll get
into the complexity of this a little bit
in the next video but it's important to
know that it is a two state two-step
commit once you've made the changes
locally you can push them up to the
remote repository just like you pulled
them down with git push so again you
don't need to memorize all of these
right now but just a little introduction
so that maybe the command line isn't so
scary